And you should be good.
Hi, welcome back to another
VC libraries Open code review.
I'm Stephanie Lawhead on STL
maintainer and today we'll be
looking at a PR again a PR.
2158 extend memcpy,
memmove and memcpy comp.
Optimizations from our contributor
Adam Busier so let me go
ahead and share out my screen.
And here we go.
Cat.
So, uh, resuming the review that I
left off last week, I got through up
to line right line 4005 of X utility.
One of our central internal headers,
not the most central, but fairly central.
Contains lots of commonly used algorithms,
so we'll be resuming there.
Adam also pushed one commit to updated
comments. Let's just check that.
It has a comma addressing the one
comment I had from last time excellent.
OK, so that's good.
Uh, let's get this to disappear.
OK? So let's go look at the code.
We got all the product code
reviewed except for X utility and
then we've got test to look at.
OK, so let's load this stiff.
Scroll down to Bright Line 4005.
I seem to recall, at least for this
top part I had chosen to split
left and right rather than inline.
Let me see if. There's 4005,
let me see if the stuff below it.
Would benefit from being split.
This part kind of yes,
not massively well yeah here.
Here this is kind of a.
I guess it's a rename plus a refactoring.
The diff isn't quite to the point
where it's unreadable. This is like.
Here this is sort of almost looks
like unrelated code getting John.
It's jumping in and out of add remove
because it sees these empty lines the.
And the diff algorithm used can be
responsible for this sort of behavior.
This down here is enough that I
think I wanna use side by side OK.
So let's do that quickly. Gear split
may as well hide whitespace changes.
I could also use the Umm,
the VS code GitHub extension,
but I'm more used to the
web UI at this point.
The VS code extension is very nice because
it lets you see an arbitrary amount of
context around the lines being edited.
You don't have to click more.
I should get used to using it. OK,
so here's where we reviewed X utility up to,
but not including this line.
I always pay attention to my
inclusive exclusive issues,
so go ahead and resolve this and
let's pick up where we left off.
OK, so this is the copy unchecked algorithm.
Uh, here we are copying a range first,
last, Umm to a destination iterator.
It's internal and it's unchecked,
saying that we are going to assume that
the iterator range is valid and that
we have sufficient space and desk.
We have outer layers like the publicly
accessible stood copy function that
will perform iterator debugging
checks when possible to do things
like make sure that the first and
last iterators are not reversed.
If you accidentally say like V end
comma V begin, or if you mismatch.
Them into different containers,
like uh V begin V2 end.
That would be bad.
UM, or if the destination range does not
have enough space, we can detect that.
Sometimes if we can,
Umm sense,
how many elements are in the input
range by doing like a difference
on forward or better iterators.
And if the output range is forward or better,
and especially if it's a random access,
we can see whether we can form,
you know guest plus and or next
guest comma N and see if that's
valid and then once we have the.
Provide that the iterators are
not reversed and that there's
sufficient space in the destination.
Uh,
we can do what we call unwrap the
iterators down to either raw pointers
for contiguous things or unchecked
class types that don't do iterator
debugging logic to sort of avoid overhead,
especially in debug mode.
Where we don't get inlining
or any fancy optimizations?
Uh, so that's what copy and check,
uh is doing here.
Uh, we have a note as a reminder.
Umm, that things other than just stood.
Copy will directly call this.
We don't usually know this,
but the pattern of having unchecked
helpers just exist to implement
the public functions is strong
enough that when there's direct
callers to something unchecked,
we did start adding some of these
comments here. Just as a reminder.
OK,
so this is changing from
putter copycat to ITER copycat.
That's the rename because it's being
generalized and trivially copyable.
Changes to trivially assignable
because here we are assigning
over elements that already exist.
This is not the uninitialized special
algorithm that will fill raw memory,
so this is correct.
This is that make the type traits
we're using more fine grained.
OK, sit down here.
This looks like a ranges version.
Let me expand some context.
We've got the ranges helper copy unchecked.
I can tell it's ranges because it's
got all this Sentinel stuff here.
Put her copycat,
renamed Inter Copycat.
Trivially copyable, changed.
Trivially assignable,
same rationale writing to it out that already
exists and not changing the size Sentinel.
Four thing this is the ranges idea,
trying to avoid using the
word concept to avoid.
Confusion the ranges idea that you
can have a range UM, and in C + 20 ranges.
The Sentinel that denotes the end
of the range does not have to be
the same type as the iterator,
so it's generalizing the classic iterator
pattern from CS plus 98 STL and this
allows you to have ranges like oh,
I have a pointer to a null terminated string
and I know when I'm going to hit the end,
if you traverse it.
From front to back,
but I don't know exactly where that's
going to be until we actually look
at every element so the Sentinel
can be a special type that says,
hey, I've reached the end of the
range if the iterator on the left
hand side of the comparison is
pointing to a null character.
So that's an example of a Sentinel that
does not have the same type as the iterator.
Some Sentinels can actually tell you
the size of a range that happens.
For things like, uh,
forward or better iterators where they
are the same type where the Sentinel
is the same type as the iterator,
you just do a classic difference.
It can also happen in some cases
for something I believe like a list
where the list knows its own size,
but arbitrary iterators may not.
I may be incorrect,
there is that wrong.
This is central for means that the
iterator and Sentinel can tell
you the distance between them.
This is an example of a range
that's the size range.
It knows its own size, right,
but the iterators and Sentinels
don't know the distance between them.
Thank you.
OK,
I thought I was getting that
wrong and you were close.
You know this is the important example,
but it's the important example of the other
property than the one you were looking at.
Yeah,
the size range, OK?
Awesome so yeah.
And so is Sentinel.
Four is definitely the one we want
here because at this point we're just
being given an iterator and a Sentinel,
not an entire range.
Umm, OK, so this is good?
Uh, let's Scroll down some more.
OK, now we've got copy N the version
that takes N number of elements.
UM, this is the.
Classic stood version, uh,
there is no unchecked form because
we're doing the unchecking in here.
Umm, so put a copycat random item
copycat truly compatible to trivia.
Assignable Yep,
it's not the uninitialized form,
so all good.
We've got a copy backward unchecked.
Yeah, that looks good.
Uh, this is the internal version
taking bidirectional iterators.
Put her copycat renamed ITER Copycat
trivially copyable to trivially assignable.
Yep, that's good.
Nothing about this would be different.
OK, move, unchecked,
put or move cat,
because we're going to move elements
is now it, or move cat, that's good.
Triply copyable to trivia, assignable.
Yep, the elements already exist.
Move backward unchecked and this
one goes in the opposite order.
UM, which helps in certain overlapping cases.
Uh, put her move cat litter.
Move cat, that's correct,
trebly copyable trivia assignable again.
The elements exist, so that's good.
OK, so now for something slightly different.
This is one of the things that Adam
had called out in his extensive
PR notes that I really appreciate
the changes to is all bids 0,
so this is used by the fill optimization
that we'll call memset if we're
going to fill it with an element.
And if that element happens to be zero,
we can just call memset memset and it
doesn't matter how many bytes it is,
as long as all of the bits of
that element type are zero.
I believe this is.
This was from a previous
generalization of our optimization.
This is being further extended to
handle null put her teeth because
if we are being given an element,
say say, we're being asked to fill
a range of pointers like care stars,
conscire stars, whatever,
and the element that we're given
to fill happens to be null,
Potter the literal constant that's saying,
hey, I want you to know out all these
pointers so this will detect that.
Hey if the element.
Are being given an opportunity.
We can just always return true, UM?
And we can do so at compile time.
What, uh,
this code would have done is it
would have made a constexpr for OHP.
I'm zooming in a bit.
It would have made a constexpr
per object of type model putter
and then MEM competitor runtime.
Umm, so we would get the answer.
Yes, it's all been zero,
but we would have had to call
mencom to do so for no putter.
We can just statically detect it.
So why not?
This improves cogent a little bit more.
And this does seem like a common
enough case to be worth optimizing,
like Phil,
a range of pointers with all putter.
Maybe maybe they were uninitialized before.
Maybe we need to reset them all.
Seems totally reasonable and we
can do this things to note put
out being in the type system when
things in the type system.
That's good when things like 0
is a null pointer constant are
rules that exist outside the type
system that leads to misery.
As we saw from years and years
of experience with C + 98.
So if constexpr.
This same V the tie as no putter
T then just always return true.
Otherwise do existing code.
Uh,
this is correct because we are already
taking this thing by consti ref.
So we don't need to worry about
C qualifiers is same.
V is very very strict.
It wants the type to be exactly
identical and any differences in
consonants or volatility will
cause us to report false here.
This will ignore constness,
it ignores value category because
we're already taking it by
reference so this is good.
And if somebody gives us a
volatile null pointer, well,
they deserve what they get.
UM, we'll go through this code path,
and I think I'm comp handles volatile.
I think it does.
Maybe it doesn't,
but in any event,
it's not going to be a
regression, so that's good.
And trying to think are there any
other types that we could do this for?
Brain says no, there's no other
types that are like number
that we can just say hey,
you're always 0 every other
type can store something useful.
Umm OK NEXT and I was just thinking,
UM, that you could have something
like a structures only data members
and all better but we can't sense
that without light reflection.
And plus that's would be very pathological.
Slash, unusual empty types.
I wonder if you would be interesting
to consider for that optimization.
That's interesting.
It's like how often would you be
filling a range of empty types?
How often do you full range of pointers?
This pointers all admitted a little
more common. Yes, yeah, empty types.
You do see them as things like base classes.
You see them as things like tag types.
You don't really see ranges of them
because they would be stateless.
So although I'll admit yes,
we we could potentially detect is empty.
I think it would occur.
Yeah, I think it would occur so
infrequently that it wouldn't be worth
spending extra metaprogramming here,
but that's that's an interesting
question about the compile time piece.
I mean, the sorry the runtime case.
Right, uh, yeah and this would say,
hey, UM,
if it's constexpr and value in it it
will get it will get the correct answer.
So once we get a little bit
extra runtime code Gen.
OK, so now we've got more
metaprogramming logic can compare
with operator equal. This is asking.
I'm I'm reading ahead of it.
Can we form the equality expression?
And then some of this pointer address
convertible stuff that we had before.
OK, so let's look at what's going on here.
Template on under score.
Taiwan under score Type 2 and then
class default to void inline Vars.
Our macro that expands to inline
in Cpl 17 mode and above.
We always want that for our constexpr,
bools or constexpr constants in general.
Umm, under score can compare with
operator equal defaults defaults.
Umm, but if we meet criteria it can be true.
So this one here just looks wrapped
because of the narrow window
here for Taiwan and Tai two.
This is our void T spine pattern.
We basically say hey,
we're gonna write an expression that
we want to put it inside decal type
to get its type and then smash that
type to void T using void T we're
always going to get void out of this,
so if this thing is well formed
it will be selected as the
partial specialization for this.
Uh, because any use of this will
use this classical voice default,
this will be well formed and void
is more specific, so we'll take it.
But if this expression is not well formed,
then it's vnas away and you only
have the primary template available.
This is the void T pattern for
Sheena that we conventionally use
everywhere in the STL and it once
you learn the arcane trick behind it.
It is nice and terse and fairly
simple to parse. OK, so we formed.
Deco Val and imagine her value
of type Taiwan ref.
So we're going to compare L values,
but we're not going to add any sort of
consonants if we can say that's equal
equal to a stood deco bell tie 2 ref.
Then we can compare them with operator
equal OK, because we usually compare.
L values. Which makes sense.
We would be calling this for
elements in a range.
Ah, do I like all values there?
That's interesting, uh,
I'm thinking about ohh proxies,
UM, if iterators when dereferenced,
return proxies.
Am I comfortable with L value
references being added here?
UM?
I'm not sure I'm going to
think about that for a bit.
UM, uh, only only, uh, very unusual types
would be sensitive to the difference.
Vast majority of types don't care.
OK, so then we have a.
Separate variable template.
This is is pointer address comparable?
This asks for a Taiwan and tail two.
Can we compare the pointers?
Taiwan Star and Taitu star
with operator quality.
Uh, for some of this will be true, like UM,
carestar equals constant care star.
That's totally valid,
but carestar equals in Star.
That's bogus.
There's no such conversions
that could make that works.
That would be false.
And then, regardless of what this reports,
because there's no short
circuiting at compile time,
we also asked the questions.
Is Taiwan Pointer address
convertible to type 2 or vice versa?
OK, this is interesting.
UM, this is that thing that asks.
I think this was above.
Let me see if I can find a pointer.
Address yeah this thing,
Nope, that's the.
Versus this ohh here it is.
OK. Nope, that's more use.
Was this in another header?
Oh, here it is.
This says are they the same
after ignoring CV's and?
Is it a base of is destiny base of source?
Where the pointer interconvertible,
meaning there's no point or adjustments,
so basically are the bits literally the same.
If you convert from counter
to source to pointer to text,
which is true if you're just adjusting
CV qualifiers and it's true if you're
doing this base transformation.
And we also special case.
Oh, if any of them were void.
Pointer Void star then you can
certainly, UM, convert there.
I was briefly thinking about does this
report true for something like a void
star and a function pointer star?
Which or function star which is maybe not?
But at least below we guard it with.
Can we even form the equality which is fine?
Umm, OK, so let's jump to that usage.
OK, so this is asking can we form the
equality expression between the pointers and.
If we try to convert one to two or two
to one because we don't know exactly
which order they've been given,
for example, could be they star and
derive star or drive star and basestar.
We just need one of those to be
pointer address convertible.
They don't both need to be.
Because the the compiler,
when it performs the conversion,
will select the more the more
base one to convert them to UM.
So if either of those are true,
then that means we can just
compare the pointers using mencom.
OK, I think this all makes sense to me.
Uhm, the fact that can compare with
operator equal is always answering.
The question means that we're not relying
on this to return, whether they're.
The quality comparable in all this is
merely refining UM, when the supports true.
I also see.
There's no real reason to refactor this
into terms of conjunction and disjunction.
There might be a small
throughput improvement.
To not have to ask these questions if it's
not comparable with operator equal at all.
Umm, I'm not too worried about that.
If we ever find through brushes,
we can always refactor this later.
Right now it's not really reactable
because there's no strict version of this.
These are all, uh, variable templates,
so this is this is good.
OK, so this is being used down here.
But there's one change happening here.
Uhm?
This is the implementation of canned
meme comp elements.
Uh, previously we used to ask.
Are they the same size?
And are they integral and non volatile?
And then we have a specialization.
Umm? That handles if that's false, yes.
After all these, yeah.
So that's what that was doing.
This is being changed.
We're now going to permit volatile here.
We keep the size of all in one size M2.
We keep LM one integral we
keep is it integral V LM2?
This is claim format being
kind of bad but that's OK.
OK, uh, was it intended to?
Handle volatile here.
I need to look at the discussion notes.
Uh, let me just open up a new tab 2158.
OK, this is. Camp elements.
All these functions are named similarly.
UM, OK. Pointers to pointer interconvertible.
OK, this doesn't say anything about Moon
comp. It says it disabled the memcpy
and memmove optimization for volatile.
But this meme comp was already
disabling it for volatile.
So and now that nonvolatile
logic is being removed. Uhm?
Why is this being removed?
Is integral?
Uh, because this is a standard primary,
uh, this is a standard type trait for
one of the primary type categories,
meaning the sort of the entire
universe of types is divided up into
14 or so primary type categories
like integral floating point.
No putter, void and a few others.
UM, all of those ignore
top level CV qualifiers,
so is integral int constant volatile,
int and constant model.
Inter all true here we were
excluding volatile and now
it's no longer being excluded.
Does anything else handle
that here? This ***.
Once we're satisfied that they're the
same type and they're both integral,
then you can medcomp if one or other is bool,
or if they're negative.
One values are the same,
then we handle bytes we handle.
Pointers. Otherwise, we report false,
so this would report true for volatile int.
I don't understand why
volatiles being removed there.
Ah, OK. It's being lifted up a level.
This is asking can mem comp elements UM?
And we use it, uh,
I guess we have 10 elements with
PRED in the middle here, yeah?
And then Kemp elements with
Pred is used here.
And the equal meme comp is safe helper,
this asks hey our iterator ITER one
and enter 2 contiguous iterators,
and that the iterators don't
point the volatile stuff.
So this is where volatility
is being excluded.
OK, so I believe that's correct,
but I think a comment needs to be changed,
so one of the things I look for when
code is significantly changing is that
if there are any comments around,
it is quite possible to change the code
such that the comments become inaccurate.
So double checking the comments
for validity is important here.
The volatile check is being removed.
We've got this big comment here and
this was describing the old code.
It said L1 and L.
You aren't top level cons because we
remove cons tea in an hour layer.
UM, and then we talk about integral types
being eligible when they can't be volatile,
and this was intended to
map to this check here.
That's no longer here,
so I think at a minimum,
this comment needs to be updated.
Either we we just need to strike
this bit about volatility,
or a probably better we should just add
some parenthetical note like this being.
This is being checked in.
What was the layer equal meme
comp is safe helper UM?
Or we could just describe
that it's Umm checked before.
Using this so I will ask that.
OK.
Go back to go. Back to that. Back tech.
OK? Umm it looks like the is.
Just grab the whole thing.
Etcetera checks are being lifted up to the.
Get the other thing,
uh, where it says here?
Iterator is volatile,
so it's the equal meme comp is
what I wanna do is double click
but it grabs the space at the end.
I'll guess I'll take it
and delete the space.
What piece without the space,
interesting uh,
equal encompass save helper layer,
which is fine. However, I uh,
however, the comment.
They can't be volatile.
Don't worry about hope,
I don't wanna stay there.
To comment,
they can't be volatile above.
Was referring to the checks that have
been moved. Should this comment?
Or should we add a parenthetical note to
this comment mentioning that volatility?
It's alright phrasing, Umm?
Here we said we remove consent
before using UM and copy elements.
I can just copy that volatility.
Has already been handled similar to the.
Comment above. OK, see if that makes sense.
It looks like the not as
volatile VLM one, etcetera.
Checks are being lifted up to the equal M
comp as safe helper layer, which is fine.
However the comment they can't be
volatile above was referring to
the checks that have been moved.
Should we add a parenthetical note to
this comment mentioning the volatility
has already been handled similar
to the because we removed concept
before using can member complements.
Comment above. OK.
Yeah, this is. Although this is all
like variable template metaprogramming,
UM, really it's it's a question
of like preconditions and
postconditions here are there.
This thing is assuming certain things about
its inputs that they're not convinced,
because that's already been
handled that they're not volatile,
because volatility has already been handled.
So we're just really documenting
our preconditions,
which is important because there's
no real way to debug through this
stuff when it's variable templates.
OK, Next up, uh,
we had included a performance
note in the old code saying,
hey, if you're trying to compare
like in Star devoid star,
we're just not going to
bother to handle that.
That is now being handled
by the new pointer address.
Comparable stuff so that comments going away,
so that's great.
So here this is.
After the case of we can
handle same size integrals,
uhm, which handles the usual
arithmetic conversions.
We have various other special cases like
this one which is previously added.
We can compare stood bytes even
though they're not integral here.
If we have pointers to some underlying
type one and type 2 elements.
Used to say we can compare
them only if they're the same,
pointing to the same element type.
UM, ignoring CV qualifiers.
This says if you're comparing 2 ranges
and the range elements themselves
are in Star and constant star,
then those are different types.
But comparing them,
we know that that comparing each pair
of pointers is not going to adjust any
bits in the pointers in the addresses,
so we can just call them
come on the whole thing.
This optimization I think,
actually goes back to the original.
Implementation we had circa 2007 or so uh,
when I I started working here and
it's been extended since then,
so that routines that behavior and
then additionally extends it to oh if
you're comparing in Star to voidstar,
we know that is not going to do any
sort of weird address conversions.
And that's now all centralized in
is pointer address comparable,
so that's good like that. Umm?
OK. Now this is being refactored.
There used to be pretty is
consistent with Mencom PUM.
This is now called can meme
comp elements with PRED.
So let's read the new explanation.
San memo comp elements with Pred LM1LM2 PR.
Making sure that it matches the names.
Reports whether the MEM comp
optimization is applicable given
contiguously stored elements.
This avoids having to repeat
the metaprogramming that finds
the element types OK.
L1 and L2 aren't top level concept here.
OK,
so this is talk about how we've already
handled the top of consonants and
this replaces the old stuff about.
Think about just whether the predicate
invocation. Is transparent, uh?
And this was always kind of weird,
so I'm glad to see that going away, UM.
OK, so this is handling.
Equal to OK so.
With equal to Elm 3.
Yeah, that's the name we need to
make sure that both LM1 and LM2
are convertible to LM3 without
changing object representation.
We use ITER copycat for this task.
And Ellen, three can be safely
memco comped with itself.
OK, that makes sense
because we we're on input.
We're converting L1 and L2 each to LM3.
So that needs to not change object
representation and then within equal
2 UM that comparison we need to see.
Hey, can we use them for that so template
on class under score L1L2L3 in line?
Complements, with PRED for 1/2 and.
If the predicate type happens to
be exactly equal to element 3.
And I was just thinking, oh,
but what if Ellen three is
void and we've got, UM, uh,
specialization down here, handling that.
So here we know LM3 typhoid.
So we're going to answer.
Or ask three questions.
It looks ugly because it cling format, Umm?
First we ask the bitter copycat.
Umm, if we were going to copy from
Ellen one star to Elm, three star,
we're just forming pointers.
Even though we're forming imaginary pointers,
these aren't actually being passed to us.
If that is trivially constructible. Umm?
That says without changing object
representation, I don't know if
I believe this because we also
want them to be the same size.
I need to go look this up because
something like UM, say unsigned,
care to unsigned short.
That's not that's trivial as far
as the standard is concerned,
but it's going to widen the
elements by by inserting you know
extra zeros so we can't like them.
Comp them in place.
OK, so we're gonna check that then
asked the same question for Ellen.
Two star to Ellen,
three star trivially constructable.
And can we come elements?
Elm three to Elm three.
This ignores top level CV.
OK.
It's interesting that it's
on top level volatility.
OK.
OK, I was going to check
trivially constructable.
So that's in the inter copycat.
We're online 4564.
See if we can find that
trivially constructible.
OK, this asks are your pointer address
convertible and are you truly constructible?
V This is the bit from the core language.
Is this the thing that's going to
require them to be the same size?
I'm a little nervous that we are
sort of introducing new concepts,
cargo, same concepts, new ideas.
That do not map to the standard type traits.
When I see trivially constructable,
I'm generally assuming that we're referring
to like stood is trivially constructible V.
It's it begins to be worrisome when we
start introducing extra conventions,
especially attached to existing terminology.
We've that we've already
had issues in the STL.
They haven't really caused bugs yet,
but we we just have to
be real careful about it.
Where we have type traits that are
sensitive to things like top level
CV qualifiers where the standard
primary type categories are not,
and we haven't really done a
good rigorous job of documenting
exactly which things care about.
Top level CV and which you don't.
Uhm, that that that's like
one layer of issues.
UM, that we've successfully handled so far.
Maybe we'll need to do something
about that in the future,
but this is like one step
beyond CV qualifiers.
So let me let me check this pointer.
I just convertible.
I'm pretty sure this is the one
that requires the same size.
UM ohh.
Here we go.
Here's the Tripoli constructable that's
saying same size and and compatible.
This is trivial. Cat trivially constructible
this pointer and just convertible.
This is when you're just
pointers to source and ask.
If the if the things themselves are.
Pointers, then we know.
Of course they're the same size,
but if they're not necessarily
both pointers here,
then that's will require them
to be the same size.
Yeah, this, uh,
I'm I'm more nervous about this, UM.
It doesn't mean that the usage
below is fine, uh, which is why
I was originally looking at this.
We were on 4564 I think.
Yeah, we were around here.
It is nested. That's the thing
that makes it kind of OK.
It's nested within it or copycat.
But now that I'm looking at this.
The second time.
I'm increasingly uncomfortable
with the fact that we just see
trivially constructible here,
and it expands to something more
precise and more restrictive than
just trivial constructability.
I'm going to add a comment about this
because it's really common about naming.
It could be addressed by introducing.
Either different names or more clear names.
UM, like one of the the sort of the
only thing that makes this whole
metaprogramming thing bearable, is that
our names are generally pretty precise.
When I see something like. Uh.
Like you know, iterators are contiguous.
As long as we've you know, carefully
verified the definition of this thing,
I don't need to worry too much about,
UM, the actual usage because the titrate,
you know, says what it does.
But when something says trivially
constructible and it's doing something
different than it's an opportunity to
get confused either in cases where
we really do want the more general
form given to us by the standard and
we're using something for convenience
that happens to be more restrictive,
or vice versa, which I think is more likely.
We want this more restrictive form that.
Has tests like same size and compatible,
but if we accidentally never go
through this centralized machinery,
uh, we start getting the wrong answer.
And the usage would look like,
uh, what if on, like 4564 if
we accidentally didn't say,
like inter copycat,
trivially constructible if we just said
like is trivially constructible V.
That would be super bad.
And it's the name, anything different?
UM, that didn't mirror the
standard wording so much.
I wouldn't be nervous,
because when I see some new name,
either a new arrangement of words
or ideally different words entirely,
then I don't come to it with those
assumptions from reading the standard,
like when I see what was it,
the same size and compatible?
Yeah, this does not map to
anything existing in the STL,
so if I see this a it tells me what it does,
but BI know I need to look
up the definition to check.
OK, what does it mean?
Compatible UM is that fact that trivially
constructable is using the same words,
but then is adding extra things.
I don't know if I necessarily want you
know like same size and compatible,
trivially constructible or something, but.
This I think I'm I'm concerned
about it so I'm gonna comment.
I think it's these three that
I care about now.
Yeah, I don't wanna. I don't wanna get that.
I, I guess it gives me no choice.
Uh, because this is what I would get in line.
UM, I'll just comment on this one line and
I'll say that all of them are affected, OK?
After UM.
Reading.
Usage of these. I wish I call him Constance.
Let's just say after reading I'm
usage far below these definitions.
I'm increasingly uncomfortable, UM with,
and let's be explicit about exactly
which ones trivially constructable.
Enable.
And.
The Constructable and
Signable I'm using. Umm?
Landerd terminology words as seen in.
Historically constructible, etcetera.
But adding additional conditions.
Specifically. Same size and compatible.
In all of these layers of
complicated metaprogramming.
I'm clear naming.
Is the only thing. Uhm?
Preventing massive UM confusion UM.
I believe we should choose.
Different names UM for these?
Properties. So we. To avoid.
Any confusion, conversion
confusion, confusion between?
Is trivially constructible V.
And trivially constructible.
Eccetera and they don't need to be
super duper verbose, for example, UM.
Make a. Sample here,
same size and compatible.
And you and.
Currently constructable.
It's probably too verbose, uh, but.
Introducing a different word.
Somewhere, somehow could really help.
No specific ideas yet.
Uh, hopefully this makes sense.
UM, after reading usage far
below these definitions,
I'm increasingly uncomfortable
with triple instructable.
Let me see, let me say the naming
because the logic is fine.
UM, the naming of using
standard terminology words.
I'm at the. I'll just note it,
uh, let's note at the end, UM.
The logic is fine.
This is purely a naming concern.
After eating usage far
below these definitions,
I'm increasingly uncomfortable with
the naming of trivially constructable,
trivially assignable and trivially
constructible and assignable using
standard terminology words as seen
in is truly constructible BCC
by adding additional conditions
specifically same size and compatible,
and all these layers are
complicated metaprogramming.
Clear naming is the only thing
preventing massive confusion.
I believe we should choose different
names for these properties to avoid
any confusion between instruct will
be and truly constructive etcetera.
They don't need to be super duper verbose,
for example, same size.
Compatible internally Constructable
is probably too verbose,
but introducing a different word
somewhere somehow could really help.
No specific ideas yet.
The logic is fine,
this is purely a naming concern.
OK, but we've got the same size
and compatible condition which
excludes bull shenanigans.
So we don't need to worry about
unsigned care and unsigned short,
UM, somehow activating them comp,
which would be bad. Uh, OK.
So let's resume 4564. OK, so this is good.
This is generalized. Ah, OK.
Now,
UM.
If our predicate happens to
be equal to diamond,
then we know we're just going
to directly compare L1L2,
so we can immediately ask in memp elements.
This does not remove any CV's.
Did we do that above?
Equal number compensate helper.
OK, this calls it with inner value
TUM and the iterator value type is
not going to have any CV qualifiers.
OK, so, uh, we don't need
to worry about that here.
In fact, this is sort of. No, no the.
Somebody very strange could say equal
to constant, UM, so we're moving
CV on the LM 3 is good here. OK.
OK, so no reason to worry about
CV qualifiers there next range
is equal to is also transparent,
so if we're in concepts mode and
our comparators range is equal to,
then just can elements that's good.
OK, finally equal mem comp is safe.
Got a helper.
That's being refactored a little,
uh, it reports whether we can
activate the memcor optimization for
arbitrary iterators and predicates.
It ignores couple of constants on
the iterators and on the elements.
So inline Varkens Expo bowl equal
encompass save helper refers to
answer are the iterators contiguous.
They better be if we're going
to call medcomp UM,
they're one had better not be, uh,
iterator to volatile, same for it or two.
It should not be iterator to volatile,
and we need to be able to member
comp elements with PRED it or value
item one item value T or two.
And the predicates.
OK.
OK, onward to lexicographical compare UM.
Here we're placing this logic UM,
and I'm sort of skipping over the old
logic because I'm pretty familiar with it.
I I should be referring to
it a little bit more, UM,
but I'm I've reviewed this in the past.
Umm, so when I I've seen the sync things here
just sort of inherently jumps out to me.
Template L1L2, inline varkas exportable
lux compare mencom classify elements.
OK, there was no preamble comment to this.
It's probably fine.
I think we come into it below. Do we?
Yeah, we don't. We just go
straight into Lux compare.
On the other hand,
that's sort of pre-existing.
Read comments on some of these.
Definitions OK, I'm not.
I'm not going to ask for comment there.
Maybe in the future we should add one UM
template L1L2 in one of our connection pool.
Let's compare mencom classify elements.
It's conjunction V all these
things need to be true.
Ellen Whitman because
we're gonna let's compare.
They need to be bite size.
UM, L1 needs to be a character Werble
LM2 needs to be character able.
LM one needs to be unsigned.
LM2 needs to be unsigned.
OK, and this actually does
map to what we had before,
except now it permits bool.
Is that reasonable?
Can you do bool less than unsigned care?
Yes you can, because the bull will widen.
I'm actually promoted all the way to end,
but you can definitely less than that.
Bool less than Bool that works.
In fact. We recently saw
usage of that with less than,
equal or greater than equal.
And enums. Those I think would
not be reported by his character.
Umm? Good question.
What is his character able?
That's, let's check that.
I should have been
reviewing this in PS code.
Let's see, we get this search.
OK, so this is elsewhere.
Next utility 4329. Here we go.
This reports true for bull of course.
Umm, it reports true for care.
Sign care, unsigned care and carry tease.
It does not report true for anything else.
And oh, here's an example of
what I was talking about. It it.
Does not strip top level.
UM conquers it will report true only
for exactly bull care sign care,
unsync care or carry T.
Because that's the interesting we do not.
Check enums, ohh, but UM,
enums are not less than
comparable by default I think.
Yeah, well, you know classes are not,
uh, I think you know just get promoted.
I don't.
I don't know that you know rules
well enough without looking them up.
I don't use them that often.
UM, it's certainly not a regression.
We didn't try to handle enums before.
Is unsigned, we'll report.
Things correctly, at least.
We're planning EMS.
I believe it asks what if
you had negative one? Umm?
I know for enums you do need
to provide bitmask operators.
I think for enum classes you don't get.
You don't get less than you
actually need to provide it.
I think this is fine. I'm not gonna
worry too much about you know here.
In theory we could extend the optimization,
but we we need to know that the
comparison operator is not overloaded.
The nice thing about characters
bools is they're not user defined,
so there's no way there can be
weird overloaded operators.
I think that's probably what's
preventing us from doing anything here.
When we're copying, we know,
hey, you've got an enum,
there's no way you could overload
a copy assignment operator,
but for comparisons I think you could
have a user defined operator less than.
Uh, OK. So then if we're bites.
OK, this is, uh, this is a conformance bug.
Uh, no, sorry, it's not a it's CP lip bite.
The classic gotcha that we have is saying
template diamond inline bar is incorrect.
If you're in C + 14 mode.
Because you, uh, it's technically non
conformant to explicitly specialize the
variable template, UM, without inline.
However, if you are in line,
it's totally cool. This is OK,
because CPP live bytes implies C + 17.
Would that actually means is
this should be playing in line?
I should actually check.
I think we do have cases where I think it.
In fact it might be above where
when we know we're simply live by.
We just say in line directly.
Yeah, here it is.
But can bump yeah,
here's the Preston can bump elements
because it's a CS plus 14 available.
Thing is inline var.
When CPP Lib bite is defined,
we are definitely in 17 or above mode.
So we can say plain inline constexpr bool.
We should follow the exact same pattern here.
Let me just copy this whole thing.
Actually I can. I can cite it.
UM, four, no, that's right line.
I left mine 4513 and actually utility.
Let's get this. OK so STL.
Think I should add a little search
engine that lets me type something
like UM ink and then I file name
and it it will take me there.
I should really do that.
Uhm? Actually tility.
Yeah, we just need to auto
complete this part here.
I said 4513.
Down, scroll up. Here it is.
OK, hit Y for permalink.
I want to ohh it's click and drag.
Nope no it's shift.
Click trying to reach.
Which UI we're looking at?
Excuse me, Umm yeah, OK,
this is what I want to quote.
It has to be permalink for the inline
snippet to show in the comment.
We don't need this anymore.
OK Umm this is nitpick level.
Now it's not needed for correctness
because it will expand in line,
but it does follow the existing
convention we were in the
CPP Lib Bite case for LUX.
Compare something or other.
Yep, here it is. If Dev CPP, Lib bite.
No, I don't want to come in
and that whole thing, no.
OK, maybe just sign and cooperate.
OK here we go.
Let me paste the thing OK. Copy this OK.
As this is guarded by CP Lib Bite,
we should say plain in line here, see.
OK. If Dev Sipila byte as
this is guarded by cpla byte,
we should say plain inline here.
See if the byte allow them
competing and so forth, OK?
OK, so if we're being asked
to compare I versus bite,
we will report true.
OK, that's good.
That's what we're doing before here,
except we had to repeat
bite three times. King
and if we don't recognize the
thing we report void for the PRAD,
which is how we say, hey,
you're not actually comparable.
OK Ohh wow this looks kind of terrible.
Uh, just because it's so severely wrapped.
OK UM, so we are specializing.
Let's compare mencom classified pred.
This is the primary template.
So if we don't recognize it, it's void.
But if we are specifically LM
one LM two and less of LM 3,
then we might be eligible.
So we're going to ask if.
I'm comparing LM three
things could be done with.
Let's compare because that's the comparison.
It's actually going to happen.
Then we need to make sure that
going from one to three and two to
three doesn't do weird conversions.
So this uses the type trace we just
ask about the naming inter copycat from
an imaginary LM one star to an LM,
three star if that's trivial,
meaning same size and compatible,
and it's trivial.
Then you're not gonna mess with
the bit representation at all.
And Lessing them is good and we
don't need to worry about usual
arithmetic conversions because
they're both being coerced to L3,
so we don't need to worry about
like an LM1 being wide or something
and overpowering LM 3 L M3 is
always the destination,
and similarly LM two to three
to the constructible OK,
then return less into this is as
we saw last time we'll be used
to compare the output of mencom,
so we're always needs to be int
otherwise just return void.
OK, good.
Let's diamond is transparent, UM,
so you can or we can immediately
skip any concern about that.
We just directly ask, hey is LM1LM2?
Are they like comparable?
If so, return lessons, otherwise would OK.
Greater needs to reverse the sense,
UM, so same pattern.
Gotta be careful for,
uh, copy paste those, uh,
we would compare 3 versus 3.
Here are the fact that the comparison
senses reverse doesn't matter.
It's going to be comparable from McComb.
Either way,
the reversion of the reverse Ness
happens here and then go from one
to three and from two to three.
They both say pointers. That's good.
OK great,
greater diamond is also transparent.
Uh,
so this good one and two greater infoid OK?
Uh, so for ranges guarded by if Dev concepts.
If we see ranges less we know it's
transparent so we can do this short form.
I was just thinking should we just
try from the other specialization,
but that would really be the same.
Would be one line,
one extra line of code and it
would instantiate more stuff.
Better to just repeat this here.
Uhm, so branges less compare one
LM one LM two report lessons.
For ranges, greater reports
to greater Ents, that's good.
OK, it's now the top level.
Let's compare mencom classify.
We're gonna ask, uh,
for it one it two impressed.
I just briefly think about is
that the usual naming we have.
Usually we say things like Itter,
but it it is fine.
So it wanted it to need to be contiguous
and it 1 needs to be not volatile
and not an iterator to volatile.
Umm, same for it too had better
not be iterator volatile then.
If that's true,
Amit tightening double column prad from
let's compare mencom classified pred.
Give it the inter value T this
will not have any CV qualifiers.
It value T V2 and the pred. OK.
This is sort of pre-existing.
I am not a fan of shadowing.
This is not technically shadowing,
but this is using pride in two different
sentences, so when I see this,
my brain momentarily short circuits.
This is fine, though.
I mean it's it's pretty existing, UM.
We did avoid it before by having PR,
at least in the template.
I guess we do use Pred elsewhere.
Where do we do?
We use predecessors in PR.
You could avoid this cheaply by saying PR.
We say PR here.
This avoids the duplication
by saying class PR.
Did we say, predict the
moon come classified level?
Ohh, used to be a function.
And now it's a. That's a helper here.
I'm going to ask for it to be,
uhm, just class PR because that
it's a little more consistent
with what we did above and it
avoids this weird quasi shadowing.
Do we have any other cases of class
spread that I would need to comment on?
That's the only one.
OK Ohh let me see.
Maybe I'll come to the whole thing
just so the context is clear.
Naming, uh nitpick. I recommend
templating on Umm class PR here,
which would be more consistent
with and let's get the use
of class PR above. This one.
With the definition of.
Blah above. And would avoid the.
Uh, quasi shadowing that appears in.
This horrible thing. Not really
horrible, it's just verbose.
OK, naming the pick, I recommend
completing on class under score PR here,
which would be more consistent with
the definition of lecompt classified
part above and would avoid the quasi
shadowing that appears in tightening.
Let's compare Mecom classified Pred meow
under score pred double compared. Yeah.
OK. So now, Umm.
We're going directly to lexicographical
compare before we had functions.
Let's compare unchecked.
Year
and now it's all being inlined. OK.
So that's where all that complexity is going.
It's good they these multiple layers
are sort of a holdover, uh, often,
UM, from our, uh, previous tag
dispatch era when we didn't have.
If Constexpr and we didn't
have things like decal type,
so we really needed another layer of
a function template to deduce the
unwrapped types and to switch between.
I can optimize versus.
I can't now that we have if Constexpr
unconditionally even in C + 14 mode,
because we can always use future technology
when we ask the compiler devs, pretty please.
Umm, and we have things like decltype.
UM, we no longer need separate
layers of functions.
UM, sometimes we still want
functions for helpers like with,
you know, copy unchecked,
but sometimes inlining it is just easier.
And that's the case here.
Umm, so now stood lexicographical compare?
Uh, which is a lot of syllables, uh,
we're adding top level consciousness
for our most modern convention on
everything except for the predicate.
And that could have a *****
function call operator.
For all we know,
we verify the iterators in the right order.
We unwrap them.
They're removing the constness on
you first one and you first two.
Because we're actually going to
iterate through them because we're
actually doing the fundamental loop.
That's where that's going now.
We're going to ask, OK,
the Mencom pred,
which is the thing we're going to
compare the memcpy answer from.
We're gonna lexicon lexicographical
compare remcom classify the decal
type of the unwrapped iterator.
Umm,
same for the deck type of the unwrapped
second iterator and the PRUM if constexpr UM,
so let's see if we're eligible
for the optimization.
If Mencom Pret is non void,
then we are eligible.
So let's do something cool, but wait.
If we're in under score has 6X20 mode,
then we are required to be constant expert.
This them comp thing is
incompatible at compile time,
so we need a runtime test that says if
we're in 20 mode then we had better
not be stood as constant in valuated.
Only then at runtime can we
do this cool thing.
If we turn out to be actually
being invoked for compile time,
this will turn out to be false
and we'll end up doing the the raw
loop that is constexpr friendly.
So this pattern is quite common
throughout the STL,
and if we're not eligible at
all free optimization,
we never even bother asking.
Are we constantly evaluate it?
Thanks to the wonders of if cost
expert that this also explains
why this is not an if constexpr?
Else because we do need this
fall through in the case that
the runtime test falls through,
and as a final aside,
it is extremely intentional that this is not.
If constexpr is constant evaluated,
the compiler will actually warrant you.
If you do that,
because that forces the answer always be yes,
it is constant evaluated,
which is not what you want.
This needs to be expressed as a runtime test.
OK, Umm, so if we end up being
eligible at compile time and
runtime for the optimization,
we get the differences of the
iterators and that's the number
of elements we're looking at.
We static cast from putative T to
size T we know that they're in the
right order because we verified them,
so we don't need to worry
about reverse things.
We call our helper mencom taking account.
We give it the unwrapped raw
pointers or unwrapped iterators.
And we're going to prepare for
the lesser of number one and #2.
You stood men, uh,
parenthesize to avoid macro expansion.
UM, get the answer out.
This is very similar to what we had before,
and then we compare if it is.
Less than zero if it is less than meaning,
as judged by the pred.
This handles the the reverting.
The reversing of behavior, UM,
then we'll immediately return it,
UM?
So if that if it ends up being
less than zero, we'll return that.
Otherwise, if it's greater than zero,
we definitely want to return false.
If it's exactly equal to 0,
the only way we can return true is
if NUM one is less than NUM two,
meaning the first sequence is shorter.
This handles the prefix case where your
cat is considered less than catastrophe.
If you had a sequence of care.
This is exactly equivalent
to what we had before this.
Also, by the way,
this correctly handles the case where
the comparator is stood greater that
only if you pass stood greater as the
comparison that only affects the answer
when the elements compare not equal.
Alex compare withstood Greater will
still say that a shorter sequence is.
Consider lexicographically
before the longer sequence.
It doesn't reverse that part,
because in in some sense,
let's compare.
Doesn't know that it's reverting
reversing at all.
Maybe it's only comparing the
sizes of strings or something,
it just has a rule if all the
elements are considered equivalent,
then shorter sequence is
lexicographically before longer sequence.
OK, so that's good, UM?
Next, here we go, UM.
So I I guess I guess the conclusion
that is what that means is that.
Sorting a sequence of strings by
lexicographic stood less is not,
and then sorting it or sorry,
comparing them with the greater
is not the same as just doing
it with less and then reversing
it because it's going to handle
different length strings differently.
That makes any sense.
OK, uh, otherwise if we are not eligible
for the Mencap optimization like we're
dealing with user defined types,
or if we are in context for land,
we need to do the raw loop.
So we iterate.
We've initialized everything already,
so as long as your first one
is not your last one and your
first two is not your last two,
we have elements of both sequences.
We can do the comparison at the
end of the loop, we'll increment.
First one, we'll increment first two.
We've got this void cast here to handle
overloaded operator comma because
being a standard library implementer is fun.
We have to defend against all sorts of,
UM, interesting user behavior.
Uh, something to compare?
Do it.
We're gonna compare,
uh, Derek.
You first one against Derek Fu 1st
2 using the PRED we will run it
through our debug Lt Pride helper.
This detects cases where the user
predicate is incorrect and returns true
when an element is less than itself.
That should never ever happen.
This detects incorrect use
of like less equal,
so if it's considered less
than we return true.
Otherwise we'll reverse it,
and if two is less than one,
we'll return false.
Otherwise,
we'll keep going because
they're equivalent at the end,
they are lexicographically less.
Only when the first sequence
is shorter than the 2nd,
that happens when you first
one has been exhausted.
It's equal to you last one,
and you first two is not exhausted.
It's not equal, you lastic.
So this is translating in fact.
Basically moving this code
around that was already up here.
GitHub doesn't show moves,
but that it's just a move.
If I was extremely paranoid,
I would diff before and after
as I do elsewhere here.
The code is straightforward enough that I
can visually see that it's all correct,
and it hasn't been mutated in any weird way.
OK, so that is for.
Lux compare with ipred.
Now we have Lux compare without pride.
This one is just meaning
constant all the iterators.
Nothing else is happening here.
I don't actually know why.
I guess it's too much of a change.
Uh, I forget.
How to highlight cost
four times in this case,
but that's what's happening.
And then we just pass let's diamond OK.
For the parallel version.
Expo rifraff these are all constant dying.
OK, this one's not being paralyzed right now,
so we just called the stid version.
OK,
that's good.
This one is the one that doesn't
even take a pred, but it's parallel.
Again, we're adding constant
all the iterators. OK. Yep.
OK, now in the concepts world
this is the Lex compare 3 way
for the spaceship operator.
OK, so. Template on under score on one LM,
two come on what was scanning
for not updating names.
Umm, this is Deluxe compare
3 way mencom classify comp.
By default, not eligible.
We were port and void,
but if we're given the stood compare 3 way,
Umm, function object,
then we might be eligible.
So using comp is conditional test.
We're gonna ask, can we let's compare
mencom classify elements LM one LM two.
This uses the mencom thing we defined above,
because ultimately that's what we want to do.
We want to ask, hey, are you them comparable?
But we also need to make sure.
Are these elements just
three way comparable at all?
So is it and this standard, uh,
I wanna say this is a concept
3 way comparable with concello
one WAF versus cons Ellen 2 ref.
If that's true we'll return compare
3 way using the same sort of.
This is what we're going to compare
mcoms result with otherwise void.
OK, we've got some internal concepts.
This is all guarded by CP Lib concepts.
That's because not all of our
front end support concepts,
yet they will soon. Then then this
will just turn to have six 6:20.
So if we are given Taiwan and Tai two can
strong order requires given a consti one
rough left and a constitu rough, right?
We can call strong order left, right?
This is, interestingly,
a function object in the STL,
so we do not qualify it.
I think, UM, it's not technically a function,
so it's not vulnerable to ADL.
I think the existing
conventions we don't qualify it,
but I can't remember if
we actually called this.
Ohh, that's interesting.
So here I did end up.
I think I wrote this code.
Yeah, this looks familiar.
I did qualify this because
it looks like a function.
Yes, is qualified here too.
It's technically not. UM?
Here we made sure that strong
ordering was not in scope,
and we're doing a DL call.
I would feel better with a stood here.
It is more consistent with existing usage.
I can quote this.
This is in compare line 700.
It's a nitpick, UM.
It's influenced by how
much I am hate and fear.
ADL the argument dependent lookup that
we're constantly on guard against.
When I, when I see the qualification,
I'm like, Oh no ADL, this is,
you know, fun and happy.
And when I don't see the qualification
I'm like oh, could this be ADL?
Could we be hijacked by a better overload?
Or compare? Here we go.
I wanted, Nope, I don't want this PR.
On line three, no line 700.
That's, uh,
and I've got the PR code.
Sorry about that.
Whenever I tapped my. Trackpad?
Becomes click OK. Here we go.
Get a permalink by pressing Y.
Here's the call listed strong order.
OK, go inside utility. This occurs
to all these, UM. So nitpick.
Although this.
Uhm, technically isn't a I'm function
and therefore is invulnerable to ADL.
I can expand this for any UM.
Viewers out there who are not versed in
the standard acronyms argument pendant,
I don't do this for everything
like Sheena, but may as well.
This is also not universally known.
Look up.
Umm, we've uhm. Conventionally,
uh, qualified it elsewhere.
Just to avoid any confusion.
Occurs below for.
Week order and partial. Order
UM example of. For example precedent.
It's kind of saw on this, OK?
Nitpick, although this technically
isn't a function and therefore is
invulnerable to argument dependent lookup,
we've kind of eventually qualified
elsewhere just to avoid any confusion
occurs below for weak order.
Partial order example President returns
to strong order, left, right. OK.
Ohh, and this just occurred to me,
this is called canned strong
order that thing it compared
was called can strong order.
It was here and strong order.
Answer, uh, nested within the fall back.
It's nested within this namespace.
Technically. It is actually shadowing
like there's a stood can strong
order if that's been included above,
although here I think compare
is actually included above,
but it's the same name.
I'm really uncomfortable whenever I
see the same name reused in the STL,
even if there's no actual shadowing.
I would prefer any any other name,
UM, that, or lift this up, UM.
Like here, the only reason I
nested it in was because I didn't
think anybody else needed it.
But if we actually do need it now.
This is trying to call the stud
function object that we've defined.
Lifting this out would be better.
One fewer concept and no shadowing.
Let me let me suggest that.
OK, so let me.
Shifts like this excuse me.
OK, Umm. This comment armies
thing they were go. Umm?
Actually, Umm, this uh.
I'm gonna say I'm gonna say duplicates.
This appears to.
Trump actually said 100% sure
this appears to duplicate.
I am the helper in compare.
Come play yeah it's concept canister order.
It's testing the stud function object.
Yeah, looks exactly the same, UM.
If they are indeed exactly the same,
UM, testing whether we can use the
standard function object. Uh, uh,
lifted out of let me copy the name space.
I recommend extracting the.
Helper in compare out of.
In space, compare stronger fall
back so it can be used here.
This would avoid, UM, any UM,
quasi shadowing and confusion.
OK does it look ohh and I need to say
occurs for the following concepts too.
I had nested the helper concepts in
their namespaces since I didn't expect.
Any further use of? Them.
But didn't intend to prevent wider use, OK.
This appears to duplicate the
helper and compare council.
Can strong order if they are indeed
exactly the same, testing whether we
can use the standard function object,
I recommend extracting the helper and
compare out of namespace compare string
order fall back so it can be used here.
This would avoid any
quasi shadowing confusion.
Occurs for the following concepts too.
I had nested the helper concepts
in their namespaces since I didn't
expect any further use of them,
but didn't intend to prevent wider use.
OK. Can we quarter can partial order?
OK, getting close to the end of X utility.
Let me check real quick around line 5000.
We are almost at the end.
Yeah, we're almost at the end.
OK, I'll get to the end of this uh,
file and we'll call this a
review or video review.
We're still more files to look at.
OK, here's the end of the concepts.
OK, let's see.
So this all added no.
We're going back to deletions.
Template on L1 and L2 LEX compare 3 way
mencom classify comp UM given L1L2 and the
strong order customization point object.
This is the type of the stood
strong order function object.
Using comp UM, so we are.
If we're given strong order.
We're going to ask,
can we lux compare mencom classify
elements L M1 and M2 and can we strong
order LM1LM2 meaning can we call this
strong order function object on them?
Then let's submit strong order CPO,
otherwise void OK.
For week order same question,
can we use mencom?
Can we weak order here?
I'm looking for copy paste those
if so admit week order CPO.
And finally, for partial order,
still can remember comp one and
two can we partial order L1L2?
If so, in partial order?
CPO,
OK?
Now for class it one it two and comp
the LUX compare 3 way McComb classify
given 2 iterators and a comparator.
We need X or you have one and two
contiguous iterators and it one
is not an iterator volatile and it
too is not an iterator volatile.
And that's the case.
Then let's report.
The comp returned by this I see
the same quasi shadowing that we
might be able to avoid with CMP,
so I'm going to ask for that.
Let's ask.
Let's compare 3 way mencom classify
comp give the inter value T from it one
better value T from it two and then comp.
OK here I'm trying to catch cases where
we accidentally say like it won't.
It won twice,
which would be catastrophic
and missed in a lot of cases.
OK, so this is all good,
except I'm quasi shadowing,
so I'll ask for that,
let's see.
Uhm, similar issue as before.
UM, can we use class under CMP
to avoid the quasi shadowing of?
I just avoid.
Quasi shadowing here.
Glassdoor, CMP, Yep,
that'd be nice instinct, OK?
And now the couple of function for users.
We're adding couple of accounts
to the iterators, all of them.
We already were not constant dying.
You first wanted you first two.
There's no change there.
All of this is now being lifted up.
That's being extracted into those helpers.
Umm, so we can ask here the mencom pred.
Let's call Alex compare 3 way McComb
classify the deco type of you first
one and you first two and the CMP.
If it's not void,
then we're eligible at compile time.
We need to see if we're
eligible at runtime here.
The three way is always see
us 20 so we don't need any.
If CX-20 stuff around here.
OK.
It's not constant evaluated.
Then call mencom.
If they end up being the same.
Then we need to compare the
lengths with the MEMC compared.
Otherwise compare against. Zero,
so this is not handling the greater thing.
This would be this is very
different from the, UM, plain.
Let's compare where we never wanted
to use the pred predicate that we
admitted to our metaprogramming
machinery on the links here.
Umm, the pred can't be greater,
or whatever.
It can only be.
Strong order, weak order or partial order.
Do I believe that it can be user defined?
That's interesting,
I'm gonna need to double check that.
That's extremely interesting.
What if it's a user defined
comparator that reverses the sense?
I'm going to need to check that.
This part is fine.
You compare against zero. OK, Umm.
This one's really interesting,
uh, let me. Let's compare 3 way.
We don't have any.
We don't have any test coverage for
custom uh, spaceship comparators. Umm?
Three Ohh compare 3 way.
Define clause 25.
Ohh OK, I think I think we're correct so.
This says in sort of mathematical terms,
find the smallest integer that
you see different elements,
so the first elements that don't match.
If you find 1 where it's not zero,
you just return it. If they all
end up happening to be equal to 0,
meaning they're all equivalent, then.
Uh, ohh spaceship eyes always spaceship.
OK, so this is very much like.
This is exactly like.
The stand the the classic one
where the classical one says if the
comparison resolves before the end,
return whatever the comparator set so
stood last at greater user last user,
greater whatever.
You return that, but if they end
up all being equivalent elements,
then the shorter sequence is considered less
than lexicographically less than the greater.
You don't use the user comparator there.
This here says let E of N.
We use the user comparator on the
NTH elements of the sequences.
UM, if the comparison if
there are different elements.
That we encounter return the user comparison.
If you don't then you ignore
the user comparison.
You directly open spaceship.
The lengths of these so.
The user comparison could be returning
a strong ordering of, you know,
lesser greater that's reversed.
It could be doing like a stood
greater type comparison,
but you are not supposed to
use it on this case.
So this says that we've got a bug.
We need test coverage for it as well,
OK?
And I guess I noticed this because
this pattern of using the mencom Pride
twice did not occur for the stood
lexicographical compare to the classic one.
So even though it does look like it's
consistent here that we're converting
these two spaceships over to the
mencom pred machinery, that difference
in pattern is what clued me in.
This is not what we want.
OK, so where is the bug?
I think the bug is with the new ones.
Because if Mencom finds a nonzero answer,
we found different elements.
So. Posted here.
Actually, is this an issue, are we, uh?
This may not be an issue. This we only
activate this for ones we recognize.
We only activate it for our strong order,
weak order and partial order,
not for user comparisons because we
don't know what they're going to do,
so we can't possibly call
them come before them. Ah.
So at most. At most this is
unnecessarily generalized.
I think I'm still going to ask
for it to be changed because
we can just say spaceship here.
Yeah, it affects the ohh yeah oh it's Umm.
Auto ohh we would convert the
stronger to the weaker that's
that's possible, right, yeah. Umm?
It it it does. I think it does
not affect observable behavior.
UM, but for clarity I would prefer
to see a direct use of spaceship.
Umm, I'll put it like that.
OK, and it's on the NUM ones because
if answer is not zero then we should
return whatever this returns this.
This whole thing auto the whole thing
is auto. Oh sorry, it's auto arrow,
so we've already got the return type here.
Yeah, I wanna see spaceship OK.
I'm going to comment here.
OK, Umm yeah, so horrible.
Uh, it says paragraph three of I
really need a bigger text box.
I think big thoughts.
Thank you, OK?
And we're almost at time or slightly
overtime WG 21 Dash and 4892.
That number Umm I'll keep the section
number in there for convenience.
I'm not gonna bother with all the formatting.
Chop this out so it's not distracting. That
I guess I am a little picky
and I'll put that in italics.
Gonna put some metrics here.
OK, uhm. Let's see, UM.
Although I don't believe it actually
summarize this. After some thought.
I don't believe this affects correctness,
UM, but I believe we should directly.
Spaceship. Uh, compare the.
Lengths here instead of using the.
Ma'am. Compared.
Returned by the Meta programming.
This will match the standard's
and the classic lexicographical
compare implementation more closely.
For the classic imple,
this is critical, as the UM.
Meta programmed machinery is
capable of reversing the ordering,
which we don't want to do for the.
Uh, links. Of equal prefix sequences.
UM for the UM, 3 way,
UM imple this is cosmetic as we activate
the optimization only for strong order.
I'm not gonna bother money spacing this week.
Order a partial order, none of which.
Reverse things like UM stood greater due, OK?
Lot of words. 2021 and 49.
Two out. Three way.
Three returns or E1 minus
P1 spaceship E 2 - B two.
If no such anger exists.
After some thought,
I don't believe this affects darkness.
I believe we should directly.
You say, but for clarity.
After some thought,
I don't believe this affects correctness,
but for clarity I believe we
should directly spaceship compare
the links instead of using them.
Period returned by the minute
programming this match the standard
ease and the classic lexicographical
compare implementation will
closely for the classic simple,
This is critical,
as the metaprogramming machinery capable
of reversing the ordering which we don't
want to do for the links that equal
prefix sequences for the three way input.
This is cosmetic as we activate the operation
only for strong order recorder partial order.
Another way to reverse
things like Streater do.
OK. And then add some top of
accounts and we're all good.
Uh, no ranges stuff here.
Then I see OK that is the end of X utility.
We can mark that as viewed.
OK, so let me alt click and
see what test code we have.
So you've got all the test code.
Only thing I had looked at was test list.
OK, most of it is new tasks or
sorry it's these decomposed tests.
Some new, some decomposed. OK, uh,
I will go ahead and submit this review.
I'm thanks Part 2 UM.
Have the thanks, uh, viewed this in Part 2.
Of the video review UM.
Looked at the rest of U MX utility,
UM still need to review the test. Code.
OK.
Cut.
OK so I asked for.
Come and change about the volatility because
I was a little bit confused about that.
The renaming that I don't have
any good suggestions for, uh,
the inline that's cosmetic?
Uh, avoiding the quasar,
shadowing with under score,
prepared same with under score
comp elsewhere and either stood
qualifying this or just unifying them.
And I think it should actually be unified.
Uh, the comp as I mentioned and then
the final thing with the spaceship.
So all cosmetic stuff slash
some clarity for naming?
Uh, but really no correctness concern.
So this is looking extremely
good and I think we're just gonna
need to look at the test code.
Ohh, looks like Casey has also reviewed.
This can fail in the presence
of multiple inheritance,
since the point of base in point Dr
can be equal but have differing.
Bit patterns. Is that true for
is pointer interconvertible.
I thought that's what is the interview.
This is a user.
This is a library to find.
This is why Adam Bussiere is defining,
but he uses his pointer
interconvertible base of never mind.
Yeah. But that's a good point.
We should. We should have a.
We should have a test. UM, ideally.
I can add a comment here.
I believe that the use of,
uh, I guess yeah, thank you.
Yeah, I can't spell it.
I think it's is pointer
interconvertible big.
This puppy there we go, yeah. Umm?
Handles this scenario,
but we should be sure to.
We should make sure.
And there's test coverage
for this scenario.
I haven't checked yet.
Yes, an excellent question.
Because, UM, the sandling.
This would be very bad.
Counted.
OK, cool uh, let's see.
Are there any questions for all
of the UM, topics we covered?
OK, I'm not hearing any.
So I think we can call this the end
of the Umm, uh, video code review.
I'll stop sharing my screen.
So thanks again for joining us for next week.
We may either continue looking at this or
perhaps I'll go off and review the test.
We'll be looking at another PR next time,
so thanks and see you then.